Як довго можна безпечно гуляти зі своїм малюком на вулиці?
Чи, може, краще взагалі не гуляти, коли у повітрі смог?
Залишатися в Києві чи пожити певний час у передмісті?
Вирішуючи ці питання, киянка Софія і влітку, і особливо тепер, восени,
орієнтується на дані додатку в своєму мобільному телефоні.
В останні кілька днів індекси забруднення в 2-3 рази вищі норми.
Найближчий датчик показує 115. Це небезпечно. Тож не гуляй без потреби.
Софії здається, що її малюк, а ще дитина, народження якої вона очікує за кілька місяців,
в суцільній небезпеці.
Жінка почувається безпорадною, адже вже не знає, що ще зробити для їхнього захисту.
Зачиняємо вікна, іноді коли провітрюємо, то  в нас мисочки стоять з водою.
Це хіба що так. По-іншому ніяк.
Ми не можемо ходити в масках.
Я не можу його змусити - просто закрити йому обличчя: він не буде так ходити.
Треба розуміти, що це дитина.
Смог у столиці видно неозброєним оком.
Максимальна його концентрація вранці.
Трохи менше, але все одно помітно - вдень.
На забруднення повітря поза межами усіх норм вказують одразу кілька сайтів,
розроблених громадськими організаціями упродовж останніх років для моніторингу стану повітря.
Відповідно до їх даних,  рівень забруднення в Києві
перевищує допустимі норми  в першу чергу в центрі і на лівому березі Дніпра.
Довіряти неофіційним сайтам не варто, вважають у Київській комунальній рятувальній службі.
Службу перевели на посилений режим роботи ще наприкінці літа,
і за цей час пересувна лабораторія виїжджала понад півсотні разів,
аби перевірити скарги киян на погане повітря.
Жодного разу, стверджує начальник лабораторії,
от цими газоаналізаторами не було зафіксовано перевищення норм з вмісту вуглецю.
У нормі. Нуль. Було перевищення біля цирку за вихлопними газами, тому що там дорога.
Було перевищення по оксиду азоту.
Те ж саме кажуть і в уряді, і в Гідрометцентрі та Державній службі України з надзвичайних ситуацій.
Рятувальники визнають наявність смогу,
те, що він утворюється, зокрема, через спалення листя,
стерні і через горіння торфовищ, які нині гасять.
За даними метеорологів, українці мають справу з наслідками цих факторів і антициклону.
Коли немає опадів, вітру, через різницю температур утворюється туман,
а всі викиди залишаються внизу.
Нічого надзвичайного в Україні з точки зору забруднення атмосферного повітря не трапилося.
Це звичні концентрації забруднюючих речовин, які дуже часто повторюють.
Водночас Київська мерія визнає наявність глобальної проблеми забруднення повітря.
На запит DW Головне управління Держпродспоживання відповіло,
що заходів для зменшення накопичення шкідливих речовин в приземному шарі атмосфери
вживають вже кілька місяців.
Приміром, з 7 до 10 ранку заборонений в’їзд вантажівок у Київ.
Управління закликає усі служби не допускати спалювання відходів,
листя, стерні та навіть відмовитися від приготування страв просто неба.
Хворим людям похилого віку та дітям радять обмежити перебування на відкритому повітрі
у денні години.
Водночас закривати дитячі садки, школи або змінювати графік їхньої роботи поки не планується.
Для ефективного захисту людям потрібні респіратори із фільтрами, які слід регулярно міняти.
Це одна з порад, оприлюднених у "Фейсбуці"
колишньою очільницею міністерства охорони здоров'я Уляною Супрун.
Тобто звичайної марлевої пов'язки для захисту не достатньо.
Супрун акцентує увагу, що проблема з повітрям існує по всьому світу.
Однак в Україні, вважає екологиня Катерина Полянська,
влада взагалі не просунулася з її вирішенням.
За її словами, жоден громадський сайт та навіть усі офіційні датчики разом
не показують чіткої картини того, що відбувається насправді.
А відтак експерти вже багато років в принципі не можуть
дати громадянам чіткі поради, як захиститися.
Мала б бути єдина державна система моніторингу з сертифікованими лабораторіями,
приладами, новітніми технологіями, щоб працювала вона як інформаційно-аналітична система відкрито.
І дані про стан довкілля мають бути доступними кожному громадянину.
Це має бути відкрита інформація, і це прописано як у Конституції України, так і в конвенціях та законах.
Законопроєкт про створення такої системи вже готується.
І екологи чекають на якнайшвидше його ухвалення.
Адже в довгостроковій перспективі ці дані можуть стати фактично інструкцією з вживання заходів
для зменшення забруднення повітря, для реагування служб на джерела забруднення.
Киянка Юлія останніми днями виводить свою дитину на вулиці лише на лічені хвилини.
Розповідає, що нещодавно лікувала її від бронхіту,
який пройшов, як тільки родина виїхала з Києва в Карпати.
Ми живемо на правому березі, але тим, хто живе на лівому березі, дуже не заздрю.
А що може зробити влада?
Чи є якісь спеціальні прилади? Вона нічого не може зробити, я так вважаю.
В Київській міській держадміністрації запевняють,
що вже продумали довгострокові заходи .
щодо запобігання виникнення подібних ситуацій в майбутньому
На запит DW відповіли, що збираються регулювати кількість викидів відповідно до метеопрогнозів,
виводити з житлових кварталів підприємства,
які забруднюють повітря,
впроваджувати обладнання, яке зможе виловлювати і знешкоджувати викиди,
зокрема, нейтралізатори відпрацьованих газів автомобілів.
Також не виключають заборону використання етилованого бензину.
І взагалі хочуть змінити логістику пересування транспорту Києвом:
для вантажівок побудувати окремі траси і пускати їх по об’їзних дорогах.
Тут визнають, що перелічені заходи потребують ще і змін в законодавстві.
Усе це можливо, зауважують опитані DW експерти,
коли захист довкілля стане одним з пріоритетних завдань українського уряду і парламенту.
Як мінімум, слід зупинити знищення зелених зон через хаотичну забудову і висаджувати нові дерева.
А ще - нарешті примусити екоінспекцію і правоохоронців
повноцінно реагувати на дії тих, хто забруднює довкілля.